hi I'm Linda I'm from Yale School of
Nursing and I'm here to teach you a
little bit about the human body we call
this program have bones will travel
almost everything that I show you today
will be real if it's not real I'm going
to tell you it's not real so the intent
of this is to help you learn a little
bit and make some healthy decisions
based on knowledge we're going to begin
with the lungs it's important to know
that the lungs are housed inside a bony
cage you know that you can feel them
these are your ribs real lungs so when
you look at these lungs you have to
think about what's the purpose of the
lung why do we have them yeah to help
you breathe but to help you breathe what
what are we taking in ah what's in the
air oxygen is what we need and everybody
thinks that the room is filled with a
hundred percent oxygen - truth is
there's only 21% oxygen in this room 21%
oxygen is what we need to breathe in so
we're gonna take in the oxygen and then
what happens how do we take it in
through our nostrils and our mouth right
so you take a deep breath in and you
blow it out now if you look inside your
nose what do you have inside your nose
besides boogers which is just me hair
right you have hair inside your nose
why were you made with hair inside your
nose why do you think well yeah I mean
cuz you got a there's generally a
purpose for everything why were you made
with hair in your nose right to prevent
things from coming in its your vacuum
cleaner so you have these hairs that
will start stop dirt from coming in this
is a picture from deep inside the lung
and what almost no one knows from deep
inside the lung is every inch inside
your lung has 100 hairs
100 hairs that are constantly moving
they're in motion and they're cleaning
because if any dirt got by this part the
hairs in here you still have all these
hairs that will catch the dirt you see
this this is mucus inside so this is the
wetness that is inside your body the
dirt would catch on this and then you
can see in this picture you can actually
see the COFF coming up can you see that
the person is coughing the airway opens
and up the dirt comes and now you are
coughing and your COFF is coming out at
about 60 miles an hour yeah 60 miles an
hour sneeze about 110 that's why it's
really important during flu season that
if you're gonna call for you're gonna
sneeze do it into your shirt to protect
the people that are drinking water 110
miles away on which that is going to be
blowing out okay so inside your lungs
you have those hairs that are constantly
moving right cleaning so now you took a
breath in as you took a breath in what
happened to my chest
did it get smaller did it get bigger it
expanded right you have this big muscle
here corraled the diaphragm and that big
muscle pulled down and when it pulled
down it made your lungs longer and your
ribs what do they do do they go in or do
they go out on an inhalation they pulled
out and that made the lungs wider so
wider and longer the oxygen rushes down
into my lungs because it's less than
atmospheric air so you in other words if
I'm not breathing right now do you get
there's no we're moving in but when I
inhale I am sucking the oxygen in to my
lungs to where where's it going it's
coming in through my nose it's going
down through this so put your hand right
here this is your trachea this is your
windpipe can you feel there's little
ridges on that that's cartilage that's
keeping your your trachea open if you
didn't have that cartilage and I did
this what
I do to the rubber to close it down so
you were made miraculously to always
keep all systems in place well I always
need to get air in so regardless of what
position I put my head in that cartilage
is gonna hold that open so the air came
in find the hole on the top of your neck
bring your finger down do you feel
there's a little bump right there this
is where they remember this bone the
manubrium met the body of the sternum
that bump right there is where your
trachea splits into right left mainstem
so we have a right lung and we have a
left lung okay and inside each lung are
300 million balloons
they're called alveoli fancy named form
but those balloons are waiting to get
the air and open up and for each one of
those balloons we have a very tiny blood
vessel so tiny the one red blood cell
marches through so now take a breath in
the alveolar completely expanded oxygens
in them oxygen just diffuses over
through that little alveoli or balloon
capillary level oxygen goes in and
something jumps off what jumps off
carbon dioxide so when I teach my
students about oxygen I teach it like a
Hershey's kiss I say to him I want you
to think that oxygen is a Hershey's kiss
when I give you oxygen and you eat the
Hershey's kiss you have a wrapper left
there to show you ate the Hershey's kiss
that wrapper is carbon dioxide so when
you exhale and it's wintertime here what
do you see going out carbon dioxide so
you take oxygen in it has to get to
every part of your body that's what you
run on as I was driving here this
morning my red light went on the car it
means what I'm out of gas right could I
put my coffee cup into my car no I got
to put gas in it your gas that makes you
run is oxygen
and you need to know that oxygen is in
the room but the only way it gets is
carried on the red blood cell it's the
only way it gets down to your toes only
two percent of oxygen can float in
bloodstream ninety-eight percent has got
to be attached to a red blood cell and
that red blood cell is going to that
balloon grabbing the oxygen throwing off
the co2 and off it goes down to your
toes okay so now I'm going to show you
what lungs look like so when you come up
and feel this because I'm going to want
you to I want you to feel first the
trachea so this is the trachea and I
want you to feel the rings on it right
where I told you the sternum meets the
manubrium is where the lung splits can
you see how it splits into right and
left so we're going to have a right lung
and a left lung these lungs are
completely deflated I'm gonna pump them
up in a minute and it is going to be
like a newborn baby who takes their very
first breath so when you see them you're
gonna be amazed how large they get so
I'm gonna start pumping now and you're
gonna see them start to rise and when
you see them can you see that there's an
upper lobe now can you see that upper
can you see there's a middle you see
that's a middle lobe and there's a lower
lobe so these are your lungs filled with
oxygen as I'm pumping out got that so
upper low middle low lower low this is a
normal lung now this is a 20-year smoker
so what happened what's the difference
between this one and this one okay so
why are they black
why would these lungs get black right
because every cigarette you smoke puts
those hairs to sleep for one hour one
hour so during that period of time the
lungs are not cleaning remember the
hundred hairs that I told you are
constantly moving to waive the dirt up
they're not working so as a result that
stays in there but now if you know a
smoker how do they wake up in the
morning coughing that's a good sign why
is it a good sign it shows the hairs are
awake they're working and they're doing
their job which is to clean out the
lungs so what we know is that if you
stop smoking in ten years we can take a
smokers long back to a non-smokers long
we would still have black but the truth
is you'd have black on these anyway
because of pollution okay so I'd like
you to come up and feel what the lungs
feel like so that you can actually
squeeze it so you have to put on gloves
and the reason you have to put on gloves
is to protect the lungs you could
actually touch it but then you'd ruin
them so come on up and feel the lungs
you guys come up and feel them they can
cut it out
this one at all so these are these are
lungs that were harvested so these lungs
have never been polluted polluted these
lungs ten years people ugh smoke was
blown into them to demonstrate yes I
have different sized gloves - oh come on
try this one just feel it they feel like
a nerf football I think or what a
tempurpedic bed would I think feel like
if I ever had one isn't it cool now feel
those so these feel weaker okay aren't
they cool yeah they really are feel like
house is spongy because you're feeling
the 300 balloons blowing up you can feel
inhale exhale inhale exhale so what
you've learned so far is that I hope
that your lungs are housed in a bony
cage and that bony cage is your ribs and
your lungs are really important because
they're the organs that are bringing
oxygen to every part of your body what I
have now on my model is an oxygen
machine and this oxygen machine is
saying right now it's looking through
his fingernail and it's telling me that
one red blood cell that he has is 98%
filled with oxygen and it's telling me
that his heart rate is about 110 so now
I want to just do a little demonstration
to show what happens so I'm gonna have
you try to hold it in place and I want
you to run in place right now so he's
gonna start to run like really run right
that's it he's really running in place
and now we're gonna look at his finger
and see what happened so what happens is
he is heart rate is now up to a hundred
and forty five and his oxygen level
jumps up and the reason is initially it
dropped down
because he was using more oxygen to run
when he was sitting in place standing
here next to me
he had 97% oxygen but when I made him
run really quickly that dropped the
oxygen down because he was using it more
does that make sense so what would the
body have to do to make that oxygen
level come up again it would have to
increase the heart rate and what
happened to his breathing do you notice
how what happened it's much faster
because as the heart rate pumps around
faster his lungs had to get more oxygen
in so as your heart rate goes up your
respiratory rate naturally goes up and
as a result his oxygen level stays 98
percent and his heart rate went up to
140 something and now that we're not
doing anything
look how how you're dropping back down
again so his heart rate drops back down
again so it's to show out everything
that's connected if there's not enough
oxygen in your body your lungs are gonna
say hey I need to get more oxygen all
over how could I do that your heart says
I know the way let me pump what you have
around quicker and when you pump what
you have around quicker your lungs have
to compensate by saying okay I'll
breathe faster that's the corollary
heart and lungs go together to maintain
that your oxygen level is always going
to be perfect okay all right thanks okay
so hopefully you learned that the lungs
are really important they're important
organs that you need to protect because
they're the only organs that can get
oxygen to your toes without oxygen
getting to your toes to the tip of your
nose to the top of your ears that part
does not have oxygen and will die you
know these are the only set you've got
you don't have another spare like
another pair of sneakers you can put on
these are your lungs so these can change
to these with smoking because the hairs
go to sleep and they don't clean the
good news the body will always try to
repair itself but makes more sense not
to test it and simply protect it okay